my assumption is that whoever the
president is there are certain things
that will be set in place certain
certain safety mechanisms maybe this is
a pipe dream maybe this is just
something some weight up to to uh soothe
my own insecurities about somebody who
doesn't have much well in the case of
Obama really any executive experience to
be fair the guy he's compared to all the
time John F Kennedy was was only a
senator before wasn't even a state
senator wasn't a community organizer and
walls while you might have served longer
in the Senate he was a pretty lousy
senator jab ke was so can I also can we
point out that something my blog was
bitching at me about this and they said
well Lincoln was a senator no he wasn't
he lost the lincoln-douglas debates were
part of his drive to become senator and
he lost that race Lincoln like Obama I'm
not believing and you know what I'm not
doing this to be weaselly i'm not a big
obama fan and I'm not I'm not I'm not if
I'm an independent I you know and I know
I you know if you I know if you stay in
the middle of the road you're more
likely to get run over and it's true I'd
be look there are a lot of advantages to
coming down on one set of the other and
I'm not going to do it but uh but but he
has pretty much he has a BS about it
it's as much experience if not more than
the Lincoln bid